you've probably had days where you felt
inspired when ideas just seemed to come
freely and willingly and you've probably
had days where you weren't inspired and
it can feel like a light is turned off
even ideas that were exciting the day
before can seem flat and gray and this
is perhaps one of the most difficult
problems with a creative life what to do
when you've lost that spark one option
is to just wait to wait for that spark
to return but that can feel passive
almost like you're resigning a lot of
people who've based their lives around
creative output have turned to something
fairly simple in order to tackle this
dilemma namely at it it sounds easy but
for those of us that have started and
abandoned so many things we know how
hard it can be you might have to start
just by carving out the time the writer
and Lamont for example advises her
students to pick a regular time each day
to sit down and work even if in the
beginning it just means staring at a
blank page the author Balzac would wake
up at 1:00 in the morning to write for
the next 7 hours straight
that's a little hardcore maybe for you
it's just 20 minutes but the trick is to
do it every day but these habits and
routines don't always have to be
directly related to the work Twyla Tharp
the choreographer and dancer once wrote
routine is as much part of the creative
process as the lightning bolt of
inspiration and maybe more she considers
something as simple as getting into a
cab to the gym each morning is a crucial
part of her creative life creative
people throughout history have found
routines that work for them some of them
pretty straightforward like Stravinsky
who would play about fugue every time he
sat down to work some of them get a bit
odd like counting out exactly 60 coffee
beans for the perfect morning coffee as
Beethoven allegedly did or Ben
Franklin's rigorous daily schedule that
included air bathing where he would sit
nude in the cold morning air and for
some the routines become a bit extreme
the artist Francis Bacon reportedly had
a habit of working
hungover something I don't personally
recommend inventors like Thomas Edison
Tesla and da Vinci hardly slept at night
but made a habit of napping with
regularity and then there's dr. Yeoh
Shira Nakamatsu who patented over 3300
inventions including the floppy disk his
creative process includes listening to
music and then diving underwater and
depriving himself of oxygen but your
routine doesn't have to be that extreme
they can take on many forms maybe a meal
or a milkshake or exercise or even an
object like Charles Darwin's notebook in
which he wrote down everything that he
observed which is impressive for a man
who observed so much from the breeding
patterns of field animals to his
thoughts on the viability of marriage
these routines even if they're simple
can help anchor us in something outside
of ourselves something we can reliably
do even when we're not inspired
something to keep us moving it can help
remind us that the creative life is
sometimes lived through small
repetitions the author Yale dr. o once
wrote writing a novel is like driving a
car at night you can only see as far as
your headlights but you can make the
whole trip that way
so what routines do you have and what do
you use to keep yourself going